The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Otherwise
class announcements.
Sprint task lists due
today, hopefully you all
turned them in.
Paulina's going to check
that out and make sure
that each team has a new
sprint task list turned in.
We're asking for one
of those once a week
because we want to know
the state of your game
as it is right now.
A lot of it is for our use to
track where your game is going
and how your game is going.
The actual format you're
using isn't as important to us
for this last project.
Again, if you're using
a non-standard format,
once we get to the next product
backlog presentation-- which
I believe is next week, I
could be wrong about that, it's
in Stellar-- we'll be asking
about your project management
process, what you've been
using, how it's been working,
what changes you've made,
stuff like that to know
how you're tracking what you're
doing and when you're doing it.
Yeah, so today.
I've got another minute.
Today we're going to talk
about story in video games,
then you have time to
work on your class,
and then at 3:00 PM Ed
Barrett's class is coming in.
We've got 18 folks coming
in to play test your games.
Remember, we did
require you to have
a playable digital build today.
Please test that build.
If that bill does not
get you the test data
you need, also test another one.
So if you have a paper prototype
and you want to test that,
you can test that concurrently.
Again, just like before,
having three workstations open
at each team would be awesome.
It means everybody gets to play
the games quickly and get out
quickly so that you can
then finish up working.
You don't need to test
each other's games.
So actually allow our
guests to test games first
before you start testing
each other's games today.
Any questions about
procedures and whatnot?
All right, so we're going to
talk about stories in games.
This is a lecture
that I've adapted
from a previous colleague of
ours, Claire Fernandez Vera.
She studies adventure games.
She studies games through
the lens of theater,
so she's got a really
interesting view on play
as performance.
This is much more
of a talk about what
is usable for you right
now in the games you're
making in this class.
I'll start out with talking a
little bit about bigger games,
but then I'm going
to move quickly
into talking about things are
more useful for you all right
now.
Just a question for you.
Do games tell stories?
Yes?
I see you nodded.
Why?
How?
AUDIENCE: Obviously
there are games
that are more narrative-heavy
like with cutscenes and words
and happening.
But I feel like you can
also easily convey stories
just with the images and
the way the player interacts
with the game itself.
You kind of create
a narrative then.
PROFESSOR: Great,
you did my lecture.
I'm done.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Any other ways
games tell stories?
We heard cutscenes, we heard
narrative, we heard words,
we heard pictures.
Yeah?
One more hand?
Where?
AUDIENCE: Game books
also tell stories.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Game books, the physical
things around games.
AUDIENCE: It's also really
rare and hard to do,
but it's really great when
games can tell the story
through the mechanics.
PROFESSOR: Yes, absolutely,
telling the story
through the mechanics.
Which game did you mention?
Papers, Please?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
PROFESSOR: Excellent.
So when we talk about
games and stories,
sometimes we think about these.
Actually, you're good, you
mentioned some other types
of games.
Final Fantasy 13,
Metal Gear Solid
4, both games kind of derided
for, in certain circles,
the linearness of their games.
You start the game,
you watch the movie,
you hit some buttons,
you watch the next movie,
you hit some buttons.
Some people like that,
that's one way to play games.
That's one kind of
game that is out there.
Not exactly the kind
of games that we're
making in this class.
But also not exactly the kind
of games-- not the only way
to tell stories in games,
as you just mentioned.
To make those kind of games,
we're calling them AAA games
if anybody's heard
that phrase before.
AAA just meaning expensive.
Blockbuster.
The Marvel blockbuster
movies are basically
what's happened to
film, Call of Duty
is the game version of that.
So they require many
expensive resources,
artists, sound designers.
We heard an artist
talk earlier this week
about how art's important
and why art is important,
and how difficult
it is for one person
to do all those different kinds
of tasks that are required
for a complicated game.
Just to note that
those two games
that I mentioned
previously usually
borrow techniques from cinema.
So things like camera placement,
lighting, visual effects
and sound effects, a
lot of those things
are their borrowing
concepts from cinema
that have been proven
to work in cinema,
and then just throwing
them in the game
because they know they work.
One way a AAA studio might think
about making a game with story
is, all right, so it's this
balance between interactivity
and narrative, right?
And there's this cost, so think
of that triangle as the cost.
It costs money to
make these games,
and that money is generally
either spent on people
or it's spent on time, so
people times time, basically.
And the idea is that,
all right, so we've
got this interactive
stuff going on right here,
the player presses
buttons, great.
We've got this
narrative stuff here
and I'm borrowing
comedy and tragedy.
When I say narrative, think
back to your Aristotle.
So plot, comedy,
tragedy, melodrama.
A lot of the AAA games
tend to just basically be
big melodrama pieces.
But it could be folk tales.
That narrative could be--
sometimes it has conflict,
sometimes there's not conflict.
Sometimes there's a
dramatic arc or not.
So they say, all right, so
we've got to balance the two.
And how do we do that?
State of the art AAA 2011, this
is Arkham City, that's Batman,
his parents are dead.
Press X to pay your respects.
You press the X button,
he places down the rose,
you get a nice little
cutscene reward with it
so you can see a
little bit of a movie
going on with him being grim
and putting down the rose.
But you also get a little
achievement, so it's a reward,
it's an Easter egg.
But it's a crucial back
story to the character,
they put it in the game.
They spend a lot of money
making that animation.
Not all players are going to
see it, and when they do see it,
it only lasts for a very
short period of time.
That was 2011.
It's 2014, we've got
really cool computers,
we've got Xbox One, PS4.
Your state of the art, AAA, 2014
Call of Duty: Advanced Warfare.
We've got an upgrade.
Hold X to pay respects.
Basically, it's a
quick time event.
We've seen quick time
events with other games
before, if anybody's played
Heavy Rain, if anybody's
played the Shenmue games,
Resident Evil games,
things like that.
Basically, you've got a
video footage going on,
and you can press a
button and it'll give you
a new set of video footage.
There's a lot of
animation going on,
there's a lot of
cost going into this.
I think the hope for
this kind of thing,
why it's hold X instead of
press X, is by holding X,
you're embodying that action.
Maybe you're grieving,
maybe it's praying,
maybe it's holding the button.
Maybe the longer you hold
it, the more you grieve.
So maybe there should have been
a score that's counting down
how much grief you got.
But if you've read the
internet about the game,
you notice that,
yeah, it hasn't quite
worked out the way that they
might have thought it worked.
You don't have AAA resources, so
why did I talk about all that?
And you should probably just
give up on stories, right?
I'm going to say no,
of course, that's
why I'm talking about this
for about another 45 minutes.
But some games
don't need stories
to be fun or have a meaning.
Anybody recognize the
pieces on the screen?
Tetris.
The tetrominos of Tetris.
Is there a story to Tetris?
Some people say there is.
And I'm talking about
this Tetris too,
there's not even color in that.
You can't even tell what the
tetrominos are once they hit
the pile, they're just there.
And actually, that might
be that-- I don't know,
I think the bottom
of that bottom row
is the bottom of the
bucket that's holding it.
So our own MIT's
Media Lab Janet Murray
would say that Tetris is the
monotony of the work day,
of putting things
in their places.
Another professor, Jim G. over
at University of Wisconsin
Madison, he says
Tetris is an escape
into the very desire for order,
control, and workable solutions
that we have all the time.
Some other less notable
but equally valid
people on the internet say
it's the story of life,
it's never won, it
always has an ending,
and that ending is your
death or everything just
piling up to the top.
Because it was made
in Russia, some people
might say that it's a
critique of communism, maybe,
or of sameness,
or of bureaucracy.
Although the creator,
the Russian creator
Alexey Pajitnov would say--
he does say-- that for him,
it's about playing on the
edge of your abilities
and about playing to
a life well lived.
So the point of
all this stuff is
people read patterns in
the most abstract things.
So maybe you don't
need story, maybe
you just give them some
abstractness and then move on.
Tetris was made in 1981 or
thereabouts, on that one, 1983?
I should have put
that in the slide.
So that was 30
something odd years ago.
What if they made Tetris today?
Here's Tetris today, or one
version of Tetris today.
Why would somebody make
a Tetris game with story?
This is the Japanese
only Puyo Puyo Tetris.
It's taking two
different game mechanics
and splicing them together.
Why would they put characters
in the Tetris game?
What's up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It might, yeah.
And people are used
to seeing characters.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Possibly, yeah.
Any others?
Any other ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Tetris
already exists, so they
need to make it at least
slightly different.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely, yeah.
Actually, we were just talking
about this before class.
Would you be able
to sell this today?
Do you think this
could sell today?
You've never seen Tetris
before, it's a brand new thing,
you'd look it up.
Maybe it would,
maybe it wouldn't.
Has anybody played the game
Hexagon or Super Hexagon?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Does Hexagon or
Super Hexagon have a story?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Then why is there a
narrator and a voice?
Why is she telling you--
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like-- I feel
like it's partially to let the
player know where they are,
maybe?
PROFESSOR: How does she talk?
Kind of robotic?
AUDIENCE: It's robotic, but
also like a woman's voice.
PROFESSOR: There's a
little bit of story.
Why is the character a triangle?
AUDIENCE: Why is the
character a triangle?
PROFESSOR: The thing that
you're moving on a screen.
Why a triangle and not a square?
Or circle?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
AUDIENCE: It shows you--
PROFESSOR: I'm going to argue
that there's a little bit of--
AUDIENCE: Triangles
are non-deformable.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: They're more
sturdy than squares.
If you squish a square it
turns into like a weird slanty
square.
PROFESSOR: There you go.
AUDIENCE: Rhombus.
PROFESSOR: There's little
hints of story there.
AUDIENCE: The character
is the triangle.
I think.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One other reason
for characters is merch.
PROFESSOR: Merchandise.
Actually, yeah,
especially with this one.
What do they call the characters
when they make-- like,
Internet Explorer
as a character.
Is it [INAUDIBLE],
or is it a tomo?
AUDIENCE: It's
like something tan,
so like Internet Explorer tan.
PROFESSOR: Something tan, yeah.
So L-tan and other L-tan, maybe.
So that's story.
That's reason is the story
that historians of a game play
purpose I would argue
that Pac-Man has a story.
A noticeable story, right?
There's cutscenes
in this Pac-Man.
But what's the story of Pac-Man?
Where are the hints
of story there?
AUDIENCE: I guess it could be
in how the enemies have names?
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
And why did they give
the characters names?
Why is Blinky Blinky, and his
character, his personality
is shadow?
AUDIENCE: I think as
far as I remember,
that's really-- the English
translation is a really
poor translation of it.
In the original, it's very
clear as to their names
gives a hint as to
how they will act.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
They have deterministic actions.
So I've given them a
little bit of character,
but that's going to help you to
identify one before the other.
If anybody's played the Atari
2600 version of Pac-Man,
my first experience with it, all
the ghosts had the same image.
You couldn't tell which one
had which type of action.
They probably actually
didn't have different AI.
It was a really difficult
game for them to make.
They had to make it in two
or three weeks, I believe.
What do we gain from story?
This is where I come
in and say, this
is what I think story is
going to give to your games.
Even if you're making
a strategy game,
it doesn't matter what
kind of game you make,
you're going to get
something out of a story.
We understand our lived
experiences as stories,
so providing a story is going
to help a player understand
what's going on in the game.
If you think about what
you've ever done in the past,
you're always telling it to
another person as a story.
The way you are able
to memorize things,
often, is you're constructing
stories in your head of things
that you've done.
It's events with causes.
You're placing together,
you're finding patterns,
and you're putting
the story in there.
It helps you understand
what's going on around you.
A story can help you explain
the world to the player,
it can also encourage
the player to explore it.
So if you've got something
in the game that's
hidden later on, you
want them to find it,
you can use story to
give them hints towards,
there's this cool
thing coming up
that you might
want to check out.
On a parallel level
to explanation,
stories provide
consistency to the world.
So if you've got various things
going on within your game,
the way you can kind of massage
the differences between things
going on, between
the mechanics, is
by covering that up
with story, or rather,
embellishing and
supporting it with story
rather than covering it up.
So a couple quick videos.
When I'm talking
about story games,
especially in this
lecture, I'm mainly
talking about games with
story, not story-driven games.
The games we talked
about earlier,
those were story-driven games.
This is a game with a story.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The heroes finally meet
under the star of destiny.
PROFESSOR: That's Sophitia, in
the white we've got Cassandra.
-I'm sorry, but I
can't back down.
-What do you want?
-Battle one, fight.
PROFESSOR: Have you
heard of this game?
Soul Calibur, yeah.
I think it's 3.
2008 or 2010, I think it's from.
Did anyone catch what she said?
AUDIENCE: Don't
try to confuse me.
PROFESSOR: Don't
So KO, you basically have--
-You win.
-God, please forgive me.
PROFESSOR: God, please forgive
me, what is she talking about?
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Does anybody know
what what she was saying there
and why she was saying it?
You might only know this if
you've played the game before
and you're really,
really into the game.
So Matt?
Yeah.
So Cassandra is
Sophitia's sister,
and they're fighting
for the Soul Edge,
for this demonic sword that's
going to destroy the world.
And she has to fight her
sister and kill her sister
to get to the sword.
I think that for Sophitia's
version it's to save the world.
Why didn't she work
with her sister?
It's a fighting game, who knows?
I meant to update the
slides to something
a more modern audience
might understand.
In particular, League of Legends
does this kind of thing a lot,
right.
There's story moments
going on in games.
You had mentioned a
moment in the game.
AUDIENCE: Certain
characters on the same team,
I believe, they have
different voice prompts
or different vocal
lines that they
would say to acknowledge
that they have a history.
PROFESSOR: Does that help
you play the game Better
AUDIENCE: No, no
gameplay mechanics.
PROFESSOR: No.
It's a valid use of
story, but it's not
an efficient use of
story, especially
for your kind of games, right?
It doesn't directly connect.
The story doesn't
directly connect
to the player's
experience of the game,
but it is something
players like.
Like we talked about
with characters,
like we talked with merchandise.
And in particular, in
particular for this game,
for Soul Calibur,
why is Soul Calibur
doing this but Street
Fighter isn't doing this?
Soul Calibur stands apart
from the other fighting games
by having these complex
story lines that
are actually visible to the
player within the games.
Street Fighter does
have complex storylines,
but they're largely
fan service or outside
of the game, merchandise,
books, things like that.
You maybe see a little cutscene
or two at the end of the game,
but not while you're playing it.
And also, to really
enhance the single player
experience of the game.
That's actually how I know
of the Soul Calibur series,
I played it single player.
Because they added
an RPG to it that
was really basic and stupid,
but it made the story
a little bit more concrete.
They took the RPG
out, that's when
I stopped playing the game.
Because that story
didn't have any--
there's no reason for that
story in the gameplay anymore.
So I was asking you about
games telling stories
and how do games tell stories.
What I'm going to say now
is that technically, games
don't exactly tell stories,
if you think about it.
Like, who is the
storyteller in a game?
You.
So it's not storytelling,
it's story building.
The game, the
designer, the developer
is giving you the tools to
build a story of your own.
Why we say they're different,
so just to compare and contrast,
storytelling is continuous.
There's a one way communication,
it is from auteur and author
to the player.
The order and, more in
particular, the order of events
and disclosure of
information is determined
by the author of the game.
I'm going to show you this,
and I'm going to show you this,
and I'm going to show you that.
Story building is
more fragmented.
It could be as simple as
I'm going to show you this,
now you can go see all
these other things,
but I'm going to
pull you back and I'm
going to show you
this next thing,
and you have to see those
two things in order.
In a more open
oriented game, you
can see everything
at any point of time
depending on when you like it.
Rather than a one
way communication,
there's collaboration
between narrative design
and the players.
Anybody heard the term
narrative design before?
Or the job title
narrative designer?
What do you think
that is in a company?
And let's say Rational.
Rational has
narrative designers,
she was actually a CMS
student for Infinite.
What would a narrative designer
do in Bioshock Infinite?
AUDIENCE: Probably write all
the [INAUDIBLE] and stuff,
and all the little
pops that you hear?
And what's going on?
PROFESSOR: A little bit.
I think Ken wrote a lot of
that, Ken the director wrote
a lot of that.
They touch that, though.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Think of how the story
motivates the player and ties
into the actual gameplay.
So like, Bioshock, you're
told to do this and the reason
is the story.
I guess figuring
out how that fits in
and how the mechanics
will be fit into
PROFESSOR: Yep, they
touch that, too.
The other thing they do is,
you've got a level designer,
and you've got a writer.
And right in between, you've
got the narrative designer.
In some companies, this
isn't for all companies.
This is just for some.
In particular, this
is how I understand
how Rational works, right,
is the level designer creates
a level based on how a
person's going to play it,
how they're going
to get through it,
how they're going to get
from point A to point B.
Writer says, here's the story
I need everybody to see,
here's all the elements
I need them to see.
Narrative designer figures
out where within the level
those things are going to exist.
And we'll talk about
that when we're talking
about environmental design.
I'll point out a couple places
where a narrative designer had
an active role in that game.
All right, so I'm
going to say that we
don't need expensive cut
scenes to tell stories.
We've come up with
a few, we've kind of
touched on this a little bit.
And instead, what
I want to say is,
let's reduce the
cost of the game,
but let's keep
interactivity and narrative.
So things a player
does and the story
that the player experiences
are about similar.
So what tools are we
going to give the player
to build their story?
And where we give them the tools
depends on the type of story
we're giving them.
So there's two stories to
games that the player builds.
There's the story
of the world, which
largely is seen and heard, and
it's interpreted by the player.
And there's the story of
the player, the actions
that the player does,
and why I say told,
I kind of mean built as well.
Told is in that the
player is telling it,
not the-- so the world
might be something
that the game is
telling the player,
but the story of the
player is something
that the player is
telling back to the game,
or back to their friends,
or in their own head.
So story of the world, it's
the world's history, right.
It's the events that happen
in the fictional world
before the game starts.
You've got a lot of
control over all of this.
As a developer, you're
writing all of this.
For the player,
they're discovering it.
They're discovering
it piecemeal,
they're discovering it
through the game play.
So that story,
with a great world,
that story becomes a puzzle for
the player to want to explore.
It can be as literal as in
Myst, where it literally
is a puzzle that you were
going around and solving
a puzzle here and solving
a puzzle there, getting
little snippets of background
and putting them together
in your head to come up
with a whole view of what
the world is.
Or it could be
things like I'm going
to show you with environmental.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Ideally, too, if your
story is becoming a puzzle,
it would be really,
really cool if it
was useful to have
solved it, right?
So maybe as a player, if you
can figure out something cool
about the world that
can be useful to you
back in your game again,
that would be really great.
PROFESSOR: So the tools
are giving the player
to do that, to do exactly that.
And these are three
tools that you
have at your disposal
in your games right now.
They're really simple
and easy to use.
At least the top two are.
Title, character design, and
your environmental design.
So we're going to go
through about four tiles.
I'm going to give you
the name of the game.
I'm cheating a little bit
because I'm actually giving you
the cover art for the game.
I'd like to know what the
story is for the game.
So, Zombies Ate My Neighbors.
What is the story of
Zombies Ate My Neighbors?
It's about zombies.
What are the zombies doing?
AUDIENCE: Eating neighbors.
PROFESSOR: They're
eating neighbors.
Where does it take place?
AUDIENCE: In a neighborhood.
PROFESSOR: In a
neighborhood, all right.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: They're
coming for you.
PROFESSOR: They're
Damn right.
Yeah?
In the back?
AUDIENCE: It appears that
it's in a kind of campy style.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Maybe like '60s-ish?
PROFESSOR: Mhm.
You get the kind of
distressed woman in the front.
She's being chased by very slow,
they're slow zombies, right?
These days we have
to kind of specify.
Back in the day they
were always slow.
All right, next one.
The Earth Dies Screaming.
What's it about?
AUDIENCE: Earth dying?
AUDIENCE: Space.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
Space.
Anything else?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Aliens.
PROFESSOR: War.
Did I hear aliens?
Something?
Yeah.
Anyone recognize the title?
AUDIENCE: Was it a movie?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Do you think the game
is based on the movie?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: It actually isn't.
So the movie's from '55, '57?
I don't even remember if
it's an alien invasion movie.
It's just one of those
things where in the '50s,
you made a movie and then
somebody came and put
a title on it based on what
titles were working that day.
But they licensed it
from 20th Century Fox.
But there's these
spaceships, these very '80s
looking spaceships.
This is actually a
cartridge for the 2600.
Looks awful.
But yeah, The Earth
Dies Screaming.
What happens at the
end of the game?
AUDIENCE: The earth
dies screaming.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Arcade games, back in the day.
How did they end?
They always ended
with you dying.
It was always about
throwing another quarter,
playing it some more,
getting more time.
That actually came back
over to the consoles,
especially in the 2600 days.
We've moved beyond
that, for the most part.
In some cases, it's actually
brought back in iOS.
But yeah, Earth Dies Screaming.
All right, next
one, this is harder.
A Mind Forever Voyaging.
Ooh.
What's going on there?
AUDIENCE: Discovery.
PROFESSOR: Discovery, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So we're allowed
to look at the images
and make something up.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So you're a guy,
you imagine all these things,
and your brain interfaces
with some kind [INAUDIBLE],
so you can see that
sort of imaging.
So maybe you're exploring
all of these virtual worlds
in your head.
And maybe--
PROFESSOR: Have you played this?
AUDIENCE: I just
looked at the image.
The title image, and
that really helps me--
PROFESSOR: It does help a lot.
But yeah, that's exactly right.
Except you're wrong,
you're not a guy.
Right?
You're not a guy.
You're an AI.
Right, yeah.
I probably spoiled
it for you, it's OK.
It's an Infocom game, it's
a text adventure from 1988.
So you're exploring, text
adventures were open door,
go right, open
mailbox, die from grue.
And in this case, you're going
to all these different worlds,
and it's the mind.
So it had to do with the
AI attaining sentience
and figuring out
what was going on,
and what was around it, and what
the world was like at the time.
Really good game, cool,
little bit of tidbit of info
for these kind of games.
They came with these things
called feelies, so elements,
like physical elements,
that were shipped
with the game box that kind of
added a little bit to the game.
Because they didn't
have graphics to show
you everything.
So in this case it was
a file folder, a pen,
I think it was
related to a company
that you thought you worked for.
Here's a more recent game.
868-HACK.
What's it about?
What is 868-HACK?
AUDIENCE: A phone number.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
it's a phone number.
There's no area code, right?
Normally we'd have
an area code there.
So it's kind of referencing
back to maybe the '80s?
Are you a hacker?
Maybe.
Probably.
Anything else we can
get from the title?
We're going to come
back, I'm going
to use this example again,
because I love this game.
So titles provide clues towards
setting, character, action.
Even better, while you're
thinking of your title,
think about what
it's like on Google.
Think about marketing
right now if you're
making a game that's going
to be marketed to somewhere.
Can you Google the title
and come up with your game?
If you can, you win.
It's very hard for
some of the games,
unless you add a ton
of money into it.
Next up is character design.
Who's that?
AUDIENCE: Sonic.
PROFESSOR: Sonic.
What does Sonic do?
AUDIENCE: Runs.
PROFESSOR: He runs fast.
What's he doing here?
AUDIENCE: Stopping.
AUDIENCE: Waiting.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, why?
AUDIENCE: Because
you're not running.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
Wow, I could have
written this out.
Yeah, he's pissed.
He's like, what the hell?
Make me move.
You're not moving him
on the controller,
this is his idle animation.
So a ton of expressiveness
in this idle animation.
It's maybe three or
four frames of animation
of just him tapping his
feet, looking at you,
breaking the fourth wall.
Some really great stuff
you can do with character
design in that way.
Yeah, like why do
we know he runs?
If this were like
the first time we
saw this and this
was Christmas Day,
back in the time when we didn't
find out about games three
years before they came out.
You get this spiky-haired
dude with big feet, right?
He's fast, he runs.
So yeah.
Back to 868-HACK.
As I said, I love this game.
Where is the player
on the screen?
What element of the
screen is the player?
AUDIENCE: The tile.
PROFESSOR: Yes, which one?
AUDIENCE: Left.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
the top one, right?
What are you?
What is it doing there?
How do you think it
interacts within the system?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Walk down
and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Basically, yeah.
Do you see, you
see, I kind of said.
There's other smiley
faces there, right?
What do they do?
AUDIENCE: Chase the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so there's the
purple one, the magenta one,
the purple one, the red one.
Those are bad guys
coming to get you.
There's these little ones in
the bottom left and right.
There's a couple on the top
row that say data siphon.
That's something that
you leave behind.
So you're leaving behind
a piece of yourself
in order to claim space.
It's a territory
control game where
you drop a piece of yourself to
consume the things around it.
You can consume
the programs there
and you can use
the programs there.
But I really like it for this.
Why do you think I
like it for this?
When I'm talking
about hackers, when
I'm talking with a smiley face,
what does that connote to you?
What did I hear?
AUDIENCE: It's fun.
PROFESSOR: It's fun, yeah.
Yeah, Matt?
AUDIENCE: You're identity-less.
PROFESSOR: Your
identity-less, right?
You're anonymous.
I just kind of like that.
All right, so moving on.
Character design provides
clues towards your actions
and your verbs, although
in that last example,
it was actually not
very good at that part.
But it does give clues
towards your background, who
you are, what you are, why
you are, and then the feel.
What's the feel of that
game supposed to be.
What's the feel you're
supposed to have
when you're playing the game?
Question?
OK, cool.
Environmental design is that
third thing I talked about.
This is Portal, this is
when you first start Portal.
It's very clean,
it's very spacious,
except for that little
box that you're stuck in.
You eventually get out.
But something happens
and you see something
later in the game.
Does anybody remember
where this is?
Oh, not played it?
AUDIENCE: I'm like in
the middle of playing it.
PROFESSOR: Which level?
Like three or four,
or five or six?
Have you seen a turret yet?
AUDIENCE: Have I seen a turret?
Oh, no.
PROFESSOR: OK, all right.
Close your eyes, shut your ears.
It's 2014, come on.
Yeah, so this is
the cake is a lie.
It's later in the game.
It's actually in
a part of the game
where everything still
looks really clean,
that's as far as
I'm going to go.
Somebody left stuff back there.
This is actually something
that not a lot of players
saw when it first came out and
then a lot of other players
told each other
about it later on.
So it's also a game
event, which I'm
going to talk about
later when we're talking
about the story of the player.
But this is where level design
and narrative design meet.
So level is created,
there's a story moment that
had to be placed somewhere, the
narrative designer placed it
in a spot that was hidden,
that was hard to get to,
but still reachable.
And when we talk about
environmental storytelling,
we often talk
about-- there's been
some articles about
bad graffiti in games,
and just how trite
this has been used.
We're trying to find new
ways of doing the same thing.
But it's basically, there
was someone in there
before you, is what
happened there.
That's as far as
I'm going to go.
Environment provides
clues towards what
happened in the
past, but also what's
going to happen in the future.
And it provides clues
towards the feel,
so again, what's this game
supposed to feel like?
All right, so moving on.
We've got the story
of the player.
So there's the embedded
story of the player.
And what I mean by that
is that's the story
of the player that's
pre-established by the game.
Has everybody played Ocarina
of Time, or heard of it,
or seen it?
OK.
So you're Link, you start
out not knowing a lot
about the world,
and slowly the game
lets you know more about
what happened in the world
behind you.
You don't get to choose
to have this friend,
I don't think, right?
What's her name, Saria?
The game gave you this friend.
And actually, later on,
the other friends you get,
the game's going to
give you those, too.
You don't get to choose
to have them or not.
She gives you this ocarina.
The ocarina is a very
important aspect of the game.
So in this case, it's this
embedded story of here's
this object that
you're going to use.
It's going to be incredibly
useful for you later
in the game, to the
point where you're
going to get really
annoyed about having
to bring it up all the time
and play the same song all
the time.
But it's also part of
the character design.
It's giving you what
your capabilities,
like what are you
capable of doing?
In this case, you're
capable of playing songs
on the ocarina that do magical
effects within the game.
There's also emergent, and
this is the cooler thing
that I want to
spend more time on.
This is the result of the player
interacting with the system.
In this case, it's Sims 3.
And much of the systems
of, at least, Sims 1,
and I think still in
Sims 3, the entire game
is basically based on
Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
So I'll bring up the slide,
I think I bring that up
in a later version.
Basically, it's a sandbox game.
There are things you
can do in the game,
and the story that's being
told is the events and things
that happen to the
characters based on changes
you make in the environment.
You're not to get the same
story over and over again.
You're going to get new stories.
Some big.
Like in this case, the entire
game is that kind of thing.
In other games it's more of
a smaller aspect of the game,
it's an added bonus to the game.
The story of the player
in either of those cases
is usually told
through three things,
and these are three things
that you can use in your games
right now.
Game premise, or the goal of
the game, is your story, right.
Why are you going,
where are you going.
Game events are
things that happen
within the game, either
predetermined or emergent.
And then micronarratives,
which I'll explain
what that is on at the end.
Here is a premise.
Again, we're at MIT so we
talk about hacking, right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-A stroke of genius.
A true original.
From Introversion Software,
the award-winning makers
of Darwinia, a futuristic,
high-tech computer crime game
for the hacker elite.
Uplink.
You're an Uplink agent,
a freelance hacker.
Your clients, global
multinationals.
You hack into rival computer
systems, steal research data,
sabotage other
companies, launder money,
erase the evidence, even
frame innocent people.
And all from the comfort
of your own home.
In Uplink, you are
the hacker elite.
Find more dangerous and
profitable missions,
change peoples' academic,
and even criminal, records,
and then siphon money from
their bank account into yours.
And why not construct
the most deadly computer
virus ever designed.
But watch out.
When you're online,
you're being traced.
Uplink.
The game for the
corrupted heart,
where trust is a weakness.
PC Gamer--
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so.
Threw a lot of words at you,
but basically every single thing
inside of that game is something
you can do in the game.
You can hack another person,
you can create a virus,
you can download their
personal records,
you can change their
personal records.
Every single one of those
things mentioned in the premise,
in the trailer,
is a mechanic that
is usable within the
game in some form.
A lot of it is a user interface.
It kind of looks like a
futuristic computer terminal
or an interface terminal.
Made by the same
people, if you remember,
we showed DEFCON earlier in
the semester, same folks.
They're really good at
that kind of atmosphere,
building atmosphere.
AUDIENCE: Futuristic
for the '90s.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
still futuristic.
So game premise, that's
an easy one to get across.
Basically, it's just,
think about all the things
that you do in the game.
All those things, when you
put them together one by one,
that is the story
that the player
is going to be telling
when they play your game.
Think of it, in that
case, what they're doing
is they're using
a genre convention
and they're using some tropes
that you might already know.
Tropes can be useful,
tropes can be baggage.
Tropes are usually baggage.
But genre conventions are great,
especially when it's just,
I want to get this
theme across to you,
hard punch of you
know exactly what
you need to do.
I don't need to explain the game
to you because you know what
a hacker is supposed to do.
That's where those things
are incredibly useful.
Give me my slides.
Game events.
Has anybody played
Final Fantasy 4?
Or 2, if you played the
original, or the US version,
I mean?
So there's a character
called Rydia the Summoner,
that is not what she
looked like in the game.
That was the illustration
that she looked like.
She looked like a very
small green haired person.
She is a summoner,
she has magic powers.
What kind of magic powers are
common in the Final Fantasy
series?
What's the three basics?
AUDIENCE: Fire, ice and thunder.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Or blue or, yeah,
fire, ice, and thunder.
Exactly right.
So she's a summoner but she
has other black mage powers.
Pretty common, most characters
would have those three powers.
Except for her.
She hates fire.
You don't have fire for
a good part of the game.
There's a moment in the
game, you're at Mount Hobs,
there's an ice mountain,
you need to get through.
You can kind of see ice
in the background there.
You need to get
through the cave,
and there's a story moment.
One of the characters,
Cecil, on the left
there says she's afraid of
fire, because her village was
destroyed in a fire.
And you see a snippet of
this early in the game.
You get moments that
she's got this backstory
where traumatic past,
it's preventing her
from doing a thing.
Again, this is a trope
that's pretty common.
After this point, they're
all like yeah, you can do it,
you're awesome, you're great.
And then she gets fire,
now all of a sudden you've
got the fire skill
for this character
for the rest of the game.
Any time you play the game after
that and you're using fire,
there's some part of you that
might be remembering this story
moment and how important
the story moment was.
It's being linked back
into the game mechanics
really, really well.
But it always happens.
Every time you play the
game, that's embedded.
That's always going to happen.
One more video.
Here is an emergent event.
Has anybody seen this video?
Everyone recognizes
the game though, yeah?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All right, guys.
And just for video here, I'm
getting some mushrooms on hand
to make indefinite fire.
PROFESSOR: So indefinite
fire, that's cool.
--[INAUDIBLE] or a
castle. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Here comes the room.
-The bedroom.
[INAUDIBLE]
So let's go ahead and
just make a fireplace.
They're already made it,
as you see, is intact here.
That's the swimming pool.
So yeah.
Now all you need is
some flint and a log,
and just to chop down
a tree to get a log.
Oh yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
and to the fire.
And I always, or mostly-- uh oh.
AUDIENCE: I knew that
was going to happen.
-Crap.
PROFESSOR: He gets
some water to try it.
-Uh oh.
Sorry.
Sorry guys.
This was not supposed to happen.
And--
-Yeah.
What the hell just happened.
AUDIENCE: Fire.
-You have got to be kidding me.
[END PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: There is a
system within the game
that fire burns pretty
much anything it touches,
that's wood, and it
just travels, right.
You set this little system up,
you use it the way you use it,
and in this case,
he tried to tell
a story of building a
fire, and it turned out
he burned his house down.
You also see this
Minecraft, the Creepers.
Everybody hears that
hiss of a Creeper,
especially after
you've built something.
You've got this tension,
this moment of panic.
That's all a
memorable game event
that you're going to tell
another person after you've
played the game.
And especially
these days, you're
going to record it onto
YouTube and put it online.
This was, I think,
from 2010, because it's
an alpha build of Minecraft.
Continuing on the
theme, here's the Sims.
Has anybody had this
happen to them in The Sims?
They're just trying
to have a party,
they're trying to meet their
Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
right?
They're trying to love
and belong to each other,
and build some esteem, and
self-actualize themselves,
but they forgot about
the safety part of it.
So the oven blew up and
their fire happened,
and they all burned and died.
Common trope with The Sims.
Another example I love.
Anybody played Far Cry 2?
Yeah?
So fire exists in Far Cry 2.
I love fire.
Far Cry 2 takes place in Africa.
You're a mercenary, you're
going to find a warlord
and kill him at the
end of the game.
That's basically what
you're trying to do.
You have different
ways of doing that,
different means of doing that.
You are in the
savannah, it's very dry,
you can burn the
savannah, it's great.
And you can use that to get
past machine gun emplacement,
or set a trap for somebody.
In game character, not
another PC, but in game.
In an early version of
this, an early test,
playtesters set fire to the
savannah, and then 10, 15,
20 minutes later it said
OK, you won the game.
What happened?
Fire spread.
The boss was set in
the fire, in dry grass.
The fire spread all the
way through the game,
the many, many miles,
square miles of gameplay,
and it killed the boss
and ended the game.
I really wish they had kept
that in, or a version of that.
They ended up reducing the
spread of fire because of that,
they moved the
character from it.
But that's a game event they
could have capitalized on.
That's a piece of
emergent storytelling
that's going on that people
tell the story to each other.
In the developer circles
I heard about this in GDC
the year after this came out.
That's a great one.
So that's game events.
Next up micronarratives.
These are similar,
but different.
A micronarrative is
basically a little bit
of storytelling inside of
the game that, again, really,
really small.
So maybe it's an animation.
In this case, this
is Jet Set Willy.
In Jet Set Willy,
you are a rich guy.
You made all your money in
the previous game by mining,
and you came home, and you've
invited a bunch of friends
to your house and you had
this awesome raucous party.
And you trashed the place.
Unfortunately, you rent.
You rent a mansion instead
of buying a mansion.
And you're trying to go
to bed, and your landlady
is just like no, you
don't get to go to bed,
you don't get to sleep.
You've got to clean
all this stuff up.
She doesn't say any
of that, though.
This is all she does.
Just, she's standing in front
of the bed, she's going that.
This is for the ZX Spectrum.
I think it had
64k of RAM, maybe.
You can look that up.
Maybe it's 8k,
it's really small.
Really bad keys,
really bad keyboard.
Not a lot of graphics.
That version is actually
a later version,
I couldn't find-- this is the
closest thing we found for what
it originally looked like.
You can really see, there's
character design there,
but it's also just saying
no, you can't come back here.
AUDIENCE: 16k at launch,
it did go up to 128.
PROFESSOR: Now that I've
spewed all this out,
what can you do with all this?
So I'm actually going to show
an example of a game created
last semester by a team in this
class for the final project.
They made a game
called Sugar Rush.
What's the game about?
First, what's the title?
Well, I told the title.
Sugar Rush.
What's the game about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, candy,
candy, candy, candy, candy.
Look at him and all that candy.
And it's a kid.
So title, character
design, all working really
well right there.
Here's the game premise.
One day, strange
leafy beasts spawn
from four mysterious
portals, and they
plundered the villages,
terrorizing Candyland.
What do you think you're
going to have to do?
Kill the vegetables.
And they're mean,
because look at them.
So mean.
Now, when we say,
we said don't use
cutscenes, that doesn't mean
we say don't use exposition.
A simple screen with a
little bit instructions.
Basically, we told them,
have an instruction screen.
This was part of their
instruction screen.
They had the screen that
says these are the keys,
but also, this is what you do.
Really, really useful.
We want something that fulfills
that for a game the way
it's necessary for your game.
The difference between a game
that has something like this
and doesn't have
something like this,
is basically it's
a level of polish.
A game that has a little
bit of exposition like this
feels a little
bit more concrete.
It just feels like
it's more complete,
there's more
thought put into it.
It just feels a
little bit richer.
It's still playable without it,
it doesn't need this screen,
but this screen's
really, really helpful.
And the game play itself.
It has mechanics that are
consistent with the design.
You are a kid, you
are fighting a tomato.
What do you fight with?
You have weapons, what are
your weapons made out of?
Candy.
How do you heal yourself?
You eat candy.
How do you make new weapons?
You combine and craft candy.
Everything's revolving
around that premise of candy
is the world.
You are the lone human being
in this world that we see.
And so it's not
like Adventure Time,
you're not harvesting
candy from candy people.
The weird thing
about it, I think you
when you kill vegetables,
you take the candy from them.
Maybe they're
stealing your candy?
Yeah, you are stealing the
candy, it says plundering.
A ha, they thought ahead.
And yeah, the health points.
What are the health points
called, if you can read it?
AUDIENCE: Blood sugar.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Really simple stuff.
Really, really simple.
Just theming it,
thinking about what
you call things, how you call
things, where you place things,
what verbs you're using.
All that ties into the game.
Here's another
student made game,
it was actually made
by a larger team
over the course of the summer.
So they actually had nine
weeks to make the game.
And they had dedicated
artists on this game.
But this is a game
called Gumbeat which
we have our website there.
You are a little girl going
around chewing bubblegum
in this idyllic land
that, I don't think,
there's an information
sign up there
that says keep the place clean.
Basically, gum's not allowed.
It's not clean.
But you go around,
you recruit people.
You blow bubble gum in front of
them, they say pop the bubble,
you pop it, they're like
sweet, I'm joining you.
And then they trail behind you.
And you see on the right
there, a little guard.
Metal Gear Solid style, he's
got his own line of sight,
if he sees you, he's going to
chase you down and hit you.
Early in the
development, someone--
so if you pop the bubble on
somebody, like on your friend,
they'll get stuck with gum.
You pop the bubble on the guard,
they'll get stuck with gum
and they'll not be able to move.
But we found if you put the
bubble gum on the guard,
and you have a guard, basically
a second guard looking
for people, all the AI
was was if gum, attack.
Guard with gum found
the guard, attacked.
They didn't even
think about this,
this wasn't a feature they were
planning, it just happened.
And it happened in the space
of gameplay, play testing,
just like that
fire in Far Cry 2.
Except in this case,
they're like, that's really
freaking awesome.
We are going to polish
the crap out of that
and make that a really
interesting feature
in the game.
We're not going to tell
the player how to do that,
but we are going
to create a level
design that encourages the
player to experiment with that.
So that's where you get
that kind of game play.
So play testing is a way to
discover emergent game events.
So that's why we're asking to
play test your game, especially
people who are not you, is
to see what-- you've created
this amazing
possibility space, you
can't explore the entire
thing on your own.
They might see something
and not knowing
what the game is
possible to do and what
you should be doing
in the game, they
might come up with some cool
things to do in the game.
So play testing is key.
Lastly, not a student game, but
another favorite of mine, FTL.
There is a story to FTL
that's really complicated,
and I'm not asking you to try
to emulate that sort of thing.
It's really hard.
It's a lot of detail and
it's a lot of writing.
A lot of thought being put into
this randomized event thing.
But there's a
feature in the game
that I'm showing here
right now that is only
used on this screen.
It's probably kind of-- it was
probably a high price for them
to put the feature in.
Can you-- maybe
you can't read it.
Actually, you can't
read it that well.
Basically, you can change
the name of the characters.
This is something that
strategy games have
had for a long period of time.
I think we remember through
XCOM back in '93, '94.
Earlier?
No, '94.
So you name your characters.
If you name your
characters, you might
be more inclined to make
stories of their game play.
So I've got my ship as the good
ship GameLab with my buddies
Andrew, Philip, and
Sarah, and we're
going to be awesome
and take down--
are you taking down the empire?
I can never remember.
Empire or rebel?
Are you a rebel or
are you the empire?
AUDIENCE: You are a rebel.
PROFESSOR: We're the rebel, OK.
AUDIENCE: No, actually,
I think you're--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you're the empire.
You're trying to
take down the rebels.
AUDIENCE: You have
to run from rebels.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, cool.
So one thing that sometimes
happens with this game,
though, some players are
going to optimize it.
What did they name
their characters?
Pilot, Shields, Engines.
Who's dying?
Looks like the pilot's dying.
How do you know?
It's named Pilot.
I forget if you
can-- I don't think
you can rename characters
when you bring them back
on your ship.
I should looked that up.
If anybody plays,
take a look at that.
But you can get new
characters later on.
Whether or not you can name them
or not, you might name them,
you might not name them.
But either way, they've
spent a lot of time and money
putting this feature in, some
players aren't going to use it.
So what do you do?
You blow shit up.
The game is basically
about traveling the ship,
things catch on
fire, and hopefully,
maybe they're not
concerned about Pilot,
but they are concerned
about their ship.
So give them these cool little
game events to keep them going.
GUEST SPEAKER: So one of
the interesting things
about this kind of story
is that it's actually--
for all that you're
talking about,
it does take time and
money to create it,
but it's actually
pretty cheap to be
able to let players
name their characters.
But it's even
cheaper to do it, FTL
did at the beginning,
where they automatically
name all their characters.
When you get a random
human, the character
isn't named human
number 38, the character
is named Fred or something.
And that was actually
originally from the Kickstarter.
Backers got to have their names
in, which is kind of cool.
But it's actually worth
doing, because there
are certain kinds of
players will really
get into those names in a
way that you don't expect.
I've got two friends who
really get into their games.
One, Marc LeBlanc,
was playing XCOM.
Some of you have seen the
more recent XCOM, I assume?
But maybe not the old one?
So you can name your
characters or whatnot.
And it gives you some
names that you can use.
He had went through
the entire game,
and this is back
when games were hard,
so 40 to 60 hours of
gameplay, and he had
a squad of super uber soldiers.
They all had names.
He didn't quite have
personalities for them,
but they were kind of
like personalities.
And the second to final
battle, one of his top A
squad people got a
broken leg or something.
And he was like, oh, that's
really annoying, because I'm
going to Mars tomorrow.
Well, all my guys that
are high level are gone,
but I've got these guy's
really cool equipment.
Like he'd got the laser rifle of
doom and the super uber armor,
and so he went to his
second string squad,
the guys who were second level.
He was like you, suit up,
son, you're going to Mars.
Which for him was a story, and
it was all inside his head.
The game didn't make that.
The game did not
make that story.
The designers could not
have anticipated that story.
But in his head, because
he's the kind of player
who really tried to personify
his characters a little bit,
it was actually a really
big thing for him.
Similarly, another
one of my friends,
who will probably come in for
a lecture later, Laura Baldwin,
was playing XCOM as well.
Basically the same game.
She, in her head, kept
all the default names.
The default name is a
randomized first name
and a randomized last name.
And in her head, when she
saw the same last name,
she assumed that meant the
characters were related.
Now of course this meant
nothing in the game,
the game didn't care.
But here are the
two brothers, here
are the two sisters,
here's the married couple.
And so apparently in
the final, final battle,
you're going in to
destroy the big bad thing,
and the big bad thing does
horrible psychic damage
to all of your soldiers
on the map every turn.
And she was losing horribly.
And the husband and wife team
made it into the final room
with the big brain alien,
and the wife runs in
and discovers the final boss.
And in XCOM, you
had movement points.
So she went in and revealed the
fog of war, here's the bad guy.
She has not enough movement
points to run away.
And the husband, meanwhile,
is at the doorway
with a rocket launcher.
And so apparently, Laura,
the way she tells it,
she spent about 15 minutes
having a conversation
between these two characters.
As the husband's like,
I've got a rocket launcher,
get out of the way, honey.
And she's like, I don't
have enough movement points,
fire the rockets.
I can't.
I'll kill you.
I'm going to die
anway, fire the rocket.
And this goes back and
forth until finally she
decides all right,
boom, fires the rocket,
kills the person next to the
big bad guy, and wins the game.
But again, this
is because you had
a player who's very
cooperative, something as simple
as the names actually helped.
Now, you can't guarantee you're
going to get players like that.
But those players do exist.
And if it's easy to give
them the opportunity
to have that awesome experience
that she tells 20 years later,
do it.
It's relatively cheap.
All right.
That's it for lecture.
Any questions about
any of this stuff
and how it applies
to your games?
Anyone have an
idea what they can
do in their game right now just
thinking about any of this?
Has anybody thought about
their title, at least?
Yes, now.
OK.
All right.
So take a couple minutes.
It's 2:03 right now, break.
Work in your teams,
whatever that might be.
We've got a test coming in at
3:00, so be ready for the test
at 3:00.
I'll remind you maybe
five minutes beforehand.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So everyone,
raise your hand
if you are ready to
test at a workstation,
if you are ready to test.
So I can count off.
Two, three, four.
One, two, one, two, kind of.
All right.
You get two more minutes.
Philip, you want to talk to?
PHILLIP TAN: May I
speak to Ed's students,
I don't know if you're
scattered around,
but it would help if
you could meet up here.
You one of them?
Yeah, you can come here.
So the first thing I want to say
is thank you so much for coming
and you may have overheard
what Rick was saying earlier,
this is going to be our first
digital playtest for the games.
There are five games,
some of the teams
have multiple stations,
and there's probably not
going to be enough computers
for every single one of you
who are here.
So some of you may
be waiting in line,
but please be patient with
us, and we'll hopefully
get your feedback on at least
one or two games, if not more.
It's good for you
to give us feedback
while you are playing the game.
So if you are-- and
the students will
get more specific about the
kind of feedback that they need.
But if something's frustrating,
if something's confusing,
if something's
intriguing, or you really
think something looks cool or
is an interesting decision,
try to verbalize it so
that we can actually
realize that something's working
or something's not working.
Don't worry about our
egos at this point.
We absolutely need
the harshest criticism
that you can possibly
give us at this point,
because it's easy for
us to change things
at this point of our project.
If we learned about the
same things that bother you
two weeks from now, reversing
all of those changes
is going to be harder.
So please be harsh now.
Other than that, if anything
is confusing, do of course
vocalize it.
But the people who
are making the game
may not tell you
what to do next,
because they want to see
if you can figure it out.
If you can't figure it out,
that's not a problem with you,
that's a problem with the game.
But they need to be able
to see you sort of muddle
through what's already
there in order to figure out
how to fix it later.
So if you do start getting
frustrated, of course,
you can always say, I'm
done with this game and move
on to another game.
PROFESSOR: That's
a very valid datum.
That's a very valid datum.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah,
that's very valid data.
It's like, I'm done, no more.
That's absolutely fine.
It would be great to
be able to then tell
the students why you're done.
Maybe it's because
you feel like you've
seen everything there
is to see into a game,
and that's very different from,
I have no idea what's going on.
That's two different
reasons to leave a game,
and they need to know
what that reason is.
Otherwise this, by the way,
it is Creating Video Games.
It's 6-- what's
the course number?
PROFESSOR: 6073.
PHILLIP TAN: 6073 or CMS 611.
As a course it is joined
humanities and computer
science.
And it runs the full
semester, students actually
work on four projects
for the entire semester.
But the first three are really,
really short two week projects,
and this is kind of like
the mega big project.
PROFESSOR: If you have
questions about the class,
feel free to grab us.
We're the instructors, we can
answer those questions for you.
PHILLIP TAN: This is Rick,
I'm Phillip, you all know Ed,
and Sarah and Paulina
are over there.
Just look for any one of us
and we'll be happy to help.
PROFESSOR: So
playtest workstations,
stand up if you are a
computer that someone
can come to to play your
game, and testers in the back,
stand up if you
are a test station.
And testers please go
find a standing person
and play their game.
AUDIENCE: See what's
currently active on the sign.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And it's going to come up.
AUDIENCE: So for improvements,
I figured out what to do.
I think the instructions
are clear this time.